how do you handle if someone is looking
at you with envy or wow you know I wish
I could be doing what he's doing and
maybe they're sort of sitting on their
own talent how do you deal with
one-upmanship because I think it happens
to all of us in this town and then at
other times we're on the other end of it
as well yeah no it definitely does
happen um and like I said I'd be lying
if I didn't have that at times for
people so I Lin floating around um you
know I think I think it's a good thing I
think like I said you know that means
that you're competitive and that means
that you know there's something that you
see that you want that you know you can
do as well and and and and I think that
that's important um it's hard you know
it's hard at times you know um there
have been some friends of mine who you
know you just kind of know there's just
a feeling when you know like like okay
things are sort of changing here you
know and and and you don't I don't think
me personally I don't ever want to think
it has to do with that because I never
want to feel like that with any onion my
friends with anybody in general I really
don't like I don't feel like I don't
want it to get to a point where you
can't support you know somebody because
I think at the end of the day everything
we all do you know like I'm the person
I'll never walk out of a movie I've
never done it I don't think in my life
you know and and believe me there are
plenty of movies where like they were
tough to get through you know or play or
anything you know I but I feel like
there's always something good to be
pulled from it and and and you know what
like it's on TV or it's in theaters or
whatever it is it's on the stage like
there was a lot of effort that it took
for somebody to get it to wherever it is
that I'm watching it and I can
appreciate that you know and I feel like
you know doing something to you know or
acting out against the whole thing sort
of just a disservice to to us
individually it's just people you know
and and and you know I don't I I'm not
ignorant to the fact that like I don't
think everybody's gonna always like
every single thing I do so you know I
hope that they can find at least
something in it that they do like to at
least keep them engaged enough to to to
watch you know or even if it's just like
sometimes I even joking like men even if
it's just like they want to see the next
thing I do to see
if they can also bash that as well you
know like at least they're they're
interested to watch it you know and I
think in terms of going back to that
that's sort of competitive or that
jealous or jealousy or envy um I don't
know i mean i think i think you know we
all experience that and and and and i
guess maybe you know so sometimes it's a
you just have to understand people i
think you know and we you know we
encounter that all the time and i think
i think most you know i don't think i've
noticed it as much as an actor well
that's not sure I I definitely received
it sometimes but I also also laugh
sometimes I'm like Who am I like why why
do people why would people I would you
be jealous of me like we're all in this
at the same same sort of um you know
we're all in this this hustle together
you know what I mean it's just like guys
like you know just just I don't know I
just feel like sometimes people people
take it too seriously at times you know
it's just like just have fun like we're
here it's called the play you know it's
called a screenplay it's it's you know
like Beaton's my kids like be like a kid
you know I mean like in approach things
and just have fun and and you know it's
okay to have feelings about certain
things but I think like at the end of
the day like we're here breathing you
know and that's kind of what I what I
always like to think it's like you know
a friend of mine asked me this the other
day about a review that that went up
about one of our movies and and just
asked how I could be cool about it you
know and I'm just like because I value
people's time like I value the fact that
like at the end of the day you know they
watched a movie you know like I can't
return your time like you can return the
movie for your money or maybe even get
your dollar back from redbox if you
complain enough but like you still spent
an hour and a half of your time that I
can't repay you you know so I'm very
grateful for that I'm grateful for four
people spending that on anything that I
was involved with so I you know when I
approached like a nasty review or
whatever I look at it I'm like okay you
know again I'm not gonna like everything
I do I don't expect everybody like
everything you know that they see um so
I you know it's like sticks and stones
may break my bones but words will never
hurt me right like I'm still here I'm
still gonna wake up tomorrow and I'm
still gonna continue working you know on
the next thing so i don't know i I just
I just think that overall
people um you know have you have your
thoughts about it let it drive you let
fuel you but you know check out before
it gets to a point where it gets in your
way you know and and and and that's the
part sometimes where it's a little
difficult because you know we come
across people and it's just like they're
still holding on to it you know and and
and and that's sad because especially if
they're friends you know it's like well
you know I know enough and I value
enough of my friendships with people um
in time just with time with people where
it's like I don't you know if it's not
getting to a point where we we can be
cool about things then it's like I'm not
gonna keep pushing you know and I don't
want to sort of push past the fact that
like okay now I'm uncomfortably
understanding that like this person is
you know envious or just has negative
feeling towards me you don't I mean like
it's like I'm not gonna put myself in
that position and if that means like
we're not friends then like then that's
what's gonna happen you know you mean
because it's not doing good for either
one of us you know and or anybody for
that for that matter
you